welcome everybody to the closing
ceremony of the st louis rapid and blitz
the fourth stop of the 2022 grand chess
tour my name is christian carrillo and i
will be your host tonight first of all i
would like to start by acknowledging
shannon bailey and her staff here at the
world chess hall of fame for putting
this closing ceremony together as well
as for bringing the history and culture
of chess through the exhibitions
here at the world chess hall of fame
i would also like to thank two people
without which
none of this would be possible uh
through their love for chess as well as
the city of saint louis they have
created something magical here in saint
louis the best chess club in the world
of course i'm talking about dr ginny and
rex sinfield
[Applause]
i would also like to thank the visionary
behind the grand chester
a man that is synonymous with the word
chess that is of course mr gary kasparov
[Applause]
and of course i would also like to thank
three people that simply get things done
the executive director of the grand
chester michael kodakovsky the executive
director of the saint louis chess club
tony rich and the general manager of the
saint louis chess campus joy bray
congratulations guys
[Applause]
and of course none of this would be
possible without strong partnerships and
i would like to highlight our partner in
europe superbad as well as our partner
here in st louis the st louis chess club
and without further ado i will give the
word to the big dog tony rich
tony
[Applause]
thank you
thank you very much christian and thank
you all so much for joining us here at
the closing ceremony of the 2022 st
louis rapid and blitz
just briefly i mentioned at the opening
ceremony why you don't want to become a
super grand master right it's hard you
travel all the time you study all the
time it's painful to lose the games but
on the other hand there are lots of
great reasons why you should become a
super grand master
for one alariza has proven to us that
five days of work can earn you forty
thousand dollars that's not too bad at
all
on top of that you get to travel the
world see new places meet new people
enjoy the culture the food
and the camaraderie that comes with
being one of the best chess players
along with your fellow compatriots so
any chess players out there i encourage
you to stick with the game enjoy it and
if you become a super grand master
stop by the chess club and play even if
you don't become a super grand master
stop by the chess club and play
it's my pleasure now to introduce to you
the uh the lady who is responsible for
the chess club over the past 15 years
she and her husband rex have been the
guiding force
behind what we do here in st louis dr
jeanne singfield
[Applause]
thank you tony hey this has been a great
tournament
anyways looking at all the players that
are here
obviously there's a lot who are playing
for america who come from a variety of
other places but this is probably one of
the most interesting
international based on where people were
born seven were born
seven different countries
lots of different people a lot of them
keep trying to come to america and live
in uh you know
st louis city the chess place but what
can i say we're the chess place
so it's it's a very cool group and i
also wanted to point out
our winter
today you know how he really learned
chess
watching
the chess tournaments from the u.s chess
club and watching our videos see you
guys are playing and you're not
listening
so that's sort of cool isn't it
to have someone literally been watching
our tournament since we started
well anyway so we're having fun
and uh it's time for me to introduce rex
so when you if you think about it given
how
lousy a chess player i am and
and he's somewhat better
and can i tell my one joke
one joke when we first got married
he wanted to play chess and i said that
was okay
i mean how expensive could it be
and let me introduce the godfather of
american chess
rex infield
thank you very much genie i'll erase it
i watched our tournaments all the time
nothing great happened to me
so
it's always exciting when someone's
playing in st louis
for the first time and wins the
tournament wow this one was a big
big example of that congratulations ola
razer for your amazing performance in
the tournament
you played outstanding chess and
clinched your win early today
genie and i and the staff are very happy
for you and your victory
i would also like to thank the best
commentary team in the world i always
say this because it's true
and for the wonderful job they did with
rapid and blitz grand master yasser
cerewon peter svidler christian chorilla
and women's grand master anastasia
carlovich
[Applause]
the staff at the chess club in the world
chess hall of fame
uh work very well together and do a
phenomenal job day in and day out
they don't nearly get the accolades they
deserve but thanks to tony rich the
executive director shannon bailey the
chief curator of the world chess hall of
fame
and the one that holds it all together
for everyone joy bray
[Music]
[Applause]
i also want to thank the contractors who
do so much work for us
randy and his team at spectrum studios
kevin deputy and his crew at silverback
and the st louis chess club production
team thank you all
so
[Applause]
i have to say it was amazing to watch
alareza and ricardo dominate rapid and
blitz
they both gained a lot of rating points
they're now over 2 900
ricardo congratulations on being number
one in the world in blitz and
congratulations
congratulations to both you and alareza
for an outstanding performance thank you
[Applause]
thank you rex
and one more time i would like to
acknowledge my partners in crime the
players had a lot of fun but we had a
lot of fun as well
legends of chess commentary yasser
sarawan and peter svidler please stand
up
[Applause]
and of course woman grandmaster
anastasia carlovich for relaying the
emotions of the players the commentators
through her stories her interviews thank
you very much anastasia
[Applause]
and now it's time to get uh down to
business it's time to award the victors
we're going to start with third and
fourth place we have a two-way tie
between fabiano caruana and maxim vashir
lagrav both of them
please stand up guys
please stand up guys
both of them have earned
[Applause]
a cool
22.5 thousand dollars and 7.5 grand
chess tour points
a man
with a legion of fans in the second
place
a subpar performance for him in the
rapid portion but he showed who the man
is in the blitz section of course i'm
talking about hikaru nakamura
[Applause]
and of course
the young phenom from france
the winner of the 2022 saint louis rapid
and blitz ali reza firuja
[Applause]
ali raza please a few words
yes thank you christian
yeah it's of course um it's a dream come
true for me to win a tournament in saint
louis
i always had the dream to come to play
here but
the bigger dream was to win a tournament
here so i'm really happy to have done
that
and
yeah i want to really thank the
organizer
for all the great efforts to do the
chess tournaments it's a difficult job
really to do
and i want to thank
dr ginny and rex for
um
everything that they've done for chess
so
um and i'm
yeah i'm really looking forward to
playing sing field cup that is coming up
very soon
thank you
once again the winner of the 2022 saint
louis rapid and blitz ali reza ferruga
congratulations alireza
well this is it for us tonight we're
going to conclude the closing ceremony
thank you very much and we will see you
in just a couple of days with the
opening ceremony of the sinful cup until
then goodbye and good night
[Applause]
[Music]
you